Parkersburg West Virginia a small
industrial town in America's heartland
the government shutdown over the
southern border war may be over for now
but there are nearly two thousand
federal workers here and many of them
have gone weeks without pay it's
affected business at the corner Tina Fey
Vanessa McAuley blames the president
well my opinion is if he wants that wall
let him get off it but you're building
himself so it's gone too far
yes he has it's gone way too far as they
know affected your support for him yeah
yeah he's like a two-year-old with the
tantrum you know he just gonna have to
get over it but there are other forces
at work here too West Virginia is proud
Trump country it also has the highest
rate of opioid overdose deaths in the
nation many here believe the president's
promise that a wall will reduce the flow
of those drugs over the border well I'm
for the wall I really am I don't know of
one family that's in this area that has
not been affected by drugs not one it
was included mine included yes by the
grace of God my heroin user has been
clean for ten years so yeah I'm getting
strikes
at the bowling alley nearby federal
workers play in their weekly league
there has been deep frustration over the
shutdown but amongst some an even deeper
commitment to the principle of stronger
borders I support the president when he
is great because of immigrants but you
also have to come here legally that's
how I feel about it so you still support
the president despite feeling quite a
lot of financial pain yeah I sacrificed
my life for this country I spent 20
years in the Air Force so obviously I
believe in I believe in keeping America
safe and like so many here
this man has directly connected a
physical barrier hundreds of miles away
with reduced personal suffering
I lost the son Lewis our last year
and he was drinking and smoking dope and
stuff like that will make a difference
to other families you hope I hope so it
always makes you ashamed to say that
this is our government the state that
we're in today the one thing that seems
to unite everyone in this town is
contempt for Washington DC Democratic
Senator Joe Manchin knows it
there's nobody winning right now if
there was an election and there was a
Democrat on the ballot and there was a
Republican and there was none of the
above
known the above would win the loyalty of
trumps strongest supporters may have
been sorely tested but the diminishing
trust between the people and their
government may be the real damage
inflicted by the shutdown Hannah Thomas
Peter Sky News in Parkersburg West
Virginia